yo do you know anything about hillary
clinton hacking donald trump isn't that
crazy this [ __ ] hacked him up isn't
that crazy barely even made the news
the whole russia
hoax
hillary clinton paid for that to happen
so the whole russia trump connection was
her conjuring up some [ __ ]
hired a company to do it
what a dirty [ __ ] yo
she is a dirty [ __ ] dirt foot horse on
my car
who would call for that yo yo how you
lose are you a dirty [ __ ] and a loser
[ __ ] yeah
yeah why you do both wait what's the
full story
mark
yeah
because
it starts out a little off as strong as
opinions got mad quiet
they said huh
you're asking us for news al no i'm just
what's the first story basically hired a
spy agency yeah uh well no a guy
who used to be a british spy
and basically hired him to make some
connections between like russia
and trump
and uh forced the connections right yeah
they're not there just make them start
making that [ __ ] a thing and then that
ended up being the dossier
sure like the russia trump dossier i
believe it was and um that same company
she also hired to help her win the
primary
and uh
yeah so this was all done as like a hit
piece to make trump look bad so that she
could win the election she sucks dude
now here's here's the devil's advocate
here is like is this what every
candidate does like does every candidate
hire a company to look at the worst
possible thing that their opposition
does and then make them look bad and is
this any different from things that
trump has also done
this was a little different because it
ended up being like a congressional
investigation right it took millions and
millions of dollars in time from our
lives like
but if it's just
[ __ ] on somebody during election
time i'm like i don't know how bad this
is the fact that it came into his
presidency and he was defending it for
years and it cost taxpayers millions of
dollars like for that alone
i wonder if there's some sort of um
punishment first of all didn't is that
where the rumor came from he was getting
pissed on by russian prostitutes or
something [ __ ] like that if i'm trump
i'm beating her up she's honestly it's
on psychedelic yeah you can't start
rumors i'm getting peed on and i'm
married i'm gonna beat your ass if i see
you i still kind of believe that yeah
that [ __ ] kind of helped him locally
yeah i kind of believe really
yeah once i find out i was getting peed
on by julia fox i'm gonna like him way
more yeah 100 yeah yeah once that comes
out officially you're never going to be
a good friend to him stop pretending
there's some [ __ ] finish line to you
[ __ ] moving the goalposts all the
time
for you to be nice to your best friend
but
i will say this i think this is one of
those things where there you don't know
what the line is but when you know when
someone has crossed it like dirty
politics games this crossed the line it
is first of all you claim that side
misinformation misinformation that's how
you lost the election and you created
missiles you were the one misinforming
and you lost you lose her [ __ ] yes how
are you such a loser she kind of won she
kind of won right where did she oh she
got like more votes where that's not the
game shut the [ __ ] up
slap you like the hillary
gotta care bro now i hate that when
people bring that up the game ain't more
votes bro yeah and it's a [ __ ] game
but that's what it is yeah it should be
though now we're canada why
because like trudeau only got like 30
percent of the votes or whatever but
like you voted for the party so he got
well at least in america
it's not
oh
did you yeah about like that
did you do a little political science
degree from rollins college police yeah
whatever
did it help you calculate that yeah i'm
so indian the first time someone told me
polysack i thought it was more than one
science i'm a poli-sci major i was like
what like chemistry biology like
polytheism yeah
he looks like i was a [ __ ] [ __ ]
dude
i just put together what you were saying
probably like multiple yeah i was like i
didn't know [ __ ] clue yeah
i thought you were the smartest
[ __ ] like that you're just lazy
yeah you're just [ __ ] lazy you're a
philosopher of politics get the [ __ ] out
of here political science like what's
scientific science
what's the science about
politics can anybody break that down
somebody when somebody loses you lie a
lot there you go politics politics is
the opposite of science there's no truth
it's all feelings yeah it's all feelings
it's lies it's misinformation
we should take it away yeah
yeah it's not a major it's political
theater
[Applause]
akash said
okay all right well
one last thing can we just give a shout
out to write it for just pointing out a
bunch of [ __ ] oh that was brilliant
this is good this is brilliant
oh my god well we got a shout out
already though because this is great
dude ready ready game killing bro
ready kills man
already came to wreck last week yeah
yeah yeah shout out to the reddit memes
are on point shout outs to the reddit
community man y'all be killing it man
even when you make fun of us i'll be
killing it